y
[Música]
eeuu y lawton respondieron por escrito
que no habrá concesiones frente a las
exigencias de seguridad planteadas por
rusia en las que se incluía impedir la
entrada de ucrania al tratado del
atlántico norte e hicieron un nuevo
llamado a la diplomacia mientras que
desde parís representantes de moscú y
kiev acordaron mantener el cese al fuego
en la región del donbass
el juez liberal de la corte suprema de
eeuu stephen byers se jubilará en cuanto
termine el actual mandato del tribunal
la casa blanca aseguró que el presidente
yo vaivén mantendrá su promesa de
nominar a una jueza afroamericana por
primera vez en la historia de ese país
pero es escenario de un segundo derrame
de petróleo de la compañía repsol un
organismo del ministerio de ambiente
investiga nuevos hechos ocurridos el
martes aunque la empresa española niega
su implicación
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez damos inicio
con las respuestas por escrito que tanto
eeuu como la otan enviaron a rusia
contestando a las exigencias planteadas
por moscú en materia de seguridad la
misiva estadounidense fue entregada en
moscú por el embajador jones oliván
mientras que la de la alianza atlántica
fue entregada en bruselas ambas partes
decidieron que no habrá concesiones ante
las principales peticiones del kremlin
así las cosas la otan mantendrá su
política de puertas abiertas frente a
ucrania y asegura que sus despliegues en
el este de europa no son negociables
entretanto los representantes de rusia y
ucrania que se reunieron en parís
acordaron continuar el cese del fuego en
la región ante el donbass escuchamos al
secretario del estado de eeuu
hoy el embajador sullivan entregó
nuestra respuesta por escrito en moscú
dicho todo establece un camino
diplomático serious y rusia lo eligieron
a serious dejamos en claro que hay
principios fundamentales que estamos
comprometidos a mantener y defender
incluida la soberanía e integridad
territorial de ucrania y el derecho de
los estados a elegir sus propios
arreglos y alianzas de seguridad para
analizar esta información conectamos con
erick fajardo él es profesor e
investigador universitario con maestría
en comunicación política y especialista
en análisis de conflicto bienvenido
france24 cuál puede ser la respuesta de
rusia ahora aunque la otan ya estados
unidos se negaron a hacer concesiones
sobre las exigencias de no permitir el
ingreso de ucrania la alianza
bueno creo que primero que nada van a
intentar ajustar el ámbito de la energía
no están tratando de presionar a quien
porque saben que el timing los está
acompañando el régimen de moscú entiende
perfectamente que el invierno
acecha y definitivamente han intentado
de ellos limitar el acceso a la energía
y ha hecho un anuncio la otan y los eeuu
de que va a suministrar energía crudo si
se necesita para garantizar que el
régimen de quien pueda sobrevivir el
invierno y a la presión rusa que se está
desplegando en el ámbito militar sin
duda pero ésta es parte de una guerra
híbrida y también se está desplegando
esfuerzos enormes de parte de moscú para
limitar el acceso a energía y presionar
de esta manera en el invierno brutal que
tienen en esa área para la caída del
régimen que ellos quieren cambiar en
esta parte del continente no y qué
posibilidades reales hay de que rusia
acepte la vía diplomática cuáles son los
caminos en los que si pueden encontrar
vías comunes
parece que moscú ha encontrado un
interlocutor en macro me han visto por
lo menos que las últimas horas han
aceptado un acercamiento un diálogo con
el presidente temporal de la unión
europea hasta donde eso va a representar
una real posibilidad de acuerdos no lo
creo
esta es una contienda muy compleja en la
que si de cierta manera el hecho del
acercamiento de ucrania a la otan ha
sido el pretexto pero de fondo hay otros
temas muy complejos no está una enorme
crisis que sobreviene en rusia una
crisis energética una crisis de
alimentos una crisis muy compleja y
bueno el régimen ruso entiende
perfectamente que una guerra es el mejor
argumento y la mejor manera de patriot
erizar de hecho utilizar la crisis que
vienen las guerras siempre te dan un
magnífico perfecto para echarles la
culpa de tu incapacidad de manejar una
crisis y la crisis que viene rusia es
muy compleja en esa medida pienso que el
desplazamiento de tropas los ejercicios
militares las amenazas pero sobre todo
las demandas de rusia la otan tienen
mucho más que ver con este concierto de
necesidad de generar un espacio en el
cual la atención también de rusia se
despliegue de la crisis interna y se
dirija a esta especie de llamado a
recuperar la grandeza de lo que en otra
época fue la unión soviética señor
fajardo a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo en france24
vamos ahora a eeuu el juez del tribunal
supremo stephen breyer anunció que si se
jubilará cuando finalice este mandato
del máximo tribunal a finales de junio
se trata de una de las voces más
progresistas de la corte y con 83 años
es también el integrante de más edad
entre los nueve magistrados su retiro se
convierte en la ocasión para que el
presidente joe biden cumpla su promesa
de campaña de nombrar por primera vez en
la historia de ese país a una
afroestadounidense como jueza del
tribunal supremo el líder de la mayoría
demócrata del senado aseguró que la
persona nominada por el presidente sería
rápidamente confirmada
el nominado del presidente maiden
recibirá una rápida audiencia en el
comité judicial del senado y será
considerado y confirmado por todo el
senado estadounidense con deliberada
rapidez la reserva federal de eeuu dejó
sin cambios las tasas de interés pero
adelantó que debido al repunte de la
inflación en el país se espera que haya
una subida de las mismas en marzo el
banco central estadounidense destacó que
la creación de empleo durante los
últimos meses ha sido sólida y que la
tasa de desocupación ha bajado
sustancialmente pero señaló que la
inflación sigue elevada a causa de los
desequilibrios entre la oferta y la
demanda relacionados con la pandemia
a la luz del notable progreso que hemos
visto en el mercado laboral y la
inflación que está muy por encima de
nuestro objetivo a largo plazo del 2% la
economía ya no necesita niveles elevados
sostenidos de apoyo a la política
monetaria por eso estamos eliminando
gradualmente nuestras compras de activos
y por eso esperamos que pronto sea
apropiado aumentar el rango objetivo
para la tasa de fondos federales james
hawaiian sur en mexico el gobierno
federal envió un equipo especializado a
la ciudad de tijuana para apoyar las
investigaciones sobre el asesinato de
dos periodistas la semana pasada mataron
a los reporteros margarito martínez y a
lourdes maldonado estos homicidios
despertaron la indignación del gremio
decenas de periodistas hicieron una
vigilia frente a la secretaria de la
gobernación en ciudad de méxico para
rechazar la impunidad
pero es escenario de un segundo derrame
de petróleo en las costas del pacífico
el organismo fiscalizador adscrito al
ministerio de ambiente anunció que este
pudo haber ocurrido el martes también en
la refinería la pampilla operada por
repsol esta compañía española es la
misma involucrada en el vertimiento de
más de 6000 barriles de petróleo del 15
de enero repsol descartó un nuevo
derrame en el mar desde el imán nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías con los
detalles la marina de guerra del perú
confirmó el segundo derrame de petróleo
en el mismo lugar del desastre ecológico
ocurrido el 15 de enero esta vez se
calcula que fueron 8 barriles de
hidrocarburo que fueron vertidos al mar
cuando la transnacional repsol realizaba
tareas de inspección de una tubería ante
el imprevisto desplegó barreras de
contención la marina de guerra y el
ejército han movilizado a brigadas
multipropósito para apoyar la limpieza
de playas afectadas por el derrame de
6.000 barriles de crudo producido hace
más de 10 días diversos expertos
advierten que el petróleo del primer
derrame dejará graves daños en el
ecosistema por décadas
respecto la procuraduría especializada
en medio ambiente señaló que existen
cuatro funcionarios de repsol que
enfrentan hasta siete años de prisión
por la presunta comisión del delito de
contaminación agravada el desastre
ecológico afecta a la flora fauna y
también la economía de pescadores
artesanales a través de redes sociales
diversos colectivos civiles convocan la
población a una jornada de protesta el
próximo 31 de enero para exigir al
gobierno del presidente pedro castillo
el cese de operaciones de repsol en
otras noticias el presidente francés
emmanuel mccomb afirmó que la masacre de
1962 contra los simpatizantes de la
argelia francesa es imperdonable el 26
de enero de ese año manifestantes que
marchaban en el centro de argel fueron
baleados en un tiroteo del ejército
francés macrón dice que la masacre debe
ser reconocida esto hace parte de una
serie de actos conmemorativos de cara al
aniversario número 60 del fin de la
guerra contra argelia
en las fuerzas kurdas recuperaron el
control de una prisión en el noroeste de
síria luego de seis días de combate con
el autodenominado estado islámico las
fuerzas democráticas sirias confirmaron
la noticia
en el operativo de eeuu los apoyó con
bombardeos y tropas
los yihadistas intentaban liberar
algunos de los cerca de 5.000 presos que
están en la que antes era una escuela
parte de los detenidos son jóvenes
árabes que desafiaron el servicio
militar obligatorio porque protestaron
contra el gobierno de los kurdos al
menos 200 presos murieron en los
enfrentamientos
con esta información llegamos al final
de esta emisión de noticias a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía continúan con
nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]